aller 3è générique sais pas c'est quoi
shalalala nom personnel et au hockey moi
je les lis alors est alors attendue
alors je vous laisse trois secondes un
jonathan s'était perdu bertrange tout
prix me dire ce que c'est oui alors elle
ou oralement normalement enfin la carte
au trésor
la fia n'ont jamais pensé à un trush
itunes je vais tirer la cette frappe et
ça va descendre lapd et ça va monter
baba bâ mamadou n'a jamais mais je peux
pas te plairait des gages aux naseaux
pourquoi
non
[Applaudissements]
et cela ne les tuez pas les peintures
les anglais des gens qui merci monsieur
ça va ce que faisaient les troisièmes
derrière
[Applaudissements]